hello folks and welcome to
rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
we have lousy weather here in germany
for
the last three months
they talk about global warming
i haven't seen the sun in three months
i have plants out there i don't know how
they get their sun because there has
been no sun it's been raining or cloudy
over here
so uh is there climate change uh
probably
it is but if if it is i don't know if
it's global warming i think it's global
cooling at least from my point of view
over here
okay and what we do here is a little bit
of physics and we do a little bit of
extinction as well
and today we're going to be doing as far
as physics is concerned we're going to
look at the speed of light can light go
faster than light
and then uh
we're going to start
with extinction okay
and let me start with something else
related to extinction you'll see how it
develops and it's got to do with this
covid
bug
and some people gave me a little bit of
static because
i got my vaccine the other day okay and
so it were there were several comments
that i got from
people and here's one of them fella says
i don't take medicine from people i
don't trust
i can't believe you took the sliver bill
uh yeah i did uh no biggie
uh
you know um
what can i say i took it for a different
reason okay and i'll get to that in a
second here another fella says you got
the kill shot bill it too brute
yikes nice knowing ya if you aren't dead
after september
yeah and so we have a good old caesar
there being stabbed by uh
kobe jabs copen vaccine jabs
yeah
yeah maybe that's the way he went out i
don't know maybe they stabbed him with
vaccines
another fella says
i like this one he he offered a solution
he said sorry to hear that but hopefully
you were smart enough to put a fake arm
towards the satan in this
who want to put the poison into your
body
um
yeah that would have been a good idea
you know put put a fake arm my
prosthetic arm
[Laughter]
okay so uh there are a lot of people who
don't agree with this vaccine deal okay
one fellow did he said the following he
said
um i got my sugar water uh shooty jab a
couple of months ago because i am
not a diabetic
and i like being able to go places
and that's essentially my situation you
know
uh i like to travel i do travel i did
travel about a couple months ago i think
it was what may or june
and went to iceland
and they gave me hell i mean they put me
in a in a hotel for five days i had to
be under quarantine
and now i'm planning on going a couple
months to a much
less advanced nation
and i and i don't want the hassle i
really don't want the hassle i've got a
friend of mine who um
when they started putting these uh
requiring these masks
uh she said she wasn't gonna put it on
and so she went into supermarkets she
went into the bus she went into
everywhere and didn't use a mask
and the problem was
she got her way
right she's a tough cookie
but the problem is you know everywhere
she went she had to
fight had to struggle and the question
is whether you want to go through all
that
you know and
my decision is not to go through all
that
and you know i'd rather
be on the safe side now i don't care
about this vaccine at all i hadn't i
didn't get the vaccine in a year and a
half the only reason i got the vaccine
is i got to travel and they're going to
make life miserable for me when i get
there when i come back here here if you
come from a uh
fourth world nation you know
they put you on quarantine when you come
back 10 or 14 days i don't remember
anymore
and i don't want to go through that i
mean
i don't care about the vaccine one way
or the other
and let me tell you a little bit of
history you know my my mother she worked
for
the swedish american hospital
and she also worked for a dentist
and so she saw a lot of doctors she saw
a lot of the operations and so on she
also
looked at what the dentist did inside
your mouth
and after seeing all that she became an
atheist in medicine in other words she
never trusted doctors again i don't
think she ever went to a doctor again
okay
and she faked all our vaccines you know
all the certificates that i had when i
was a kid they were all fake
she faked them she didn't want us
getting any vaccines so i don't have any
idea what vaccines i have taken i know i
i know i have taken the sabine
sabin um
what is it the the
polio vaccine that it was a little
sugar cube you had to eat and that's
because they came to school you know i
was nine years old at the time they came
to school and they just put everybody in
line started giving them the vaccine
they didn't ask anybody you know like if
you're a jehovah's witness or anything
like that they just gave it to you and
you stood in line they gave it to you
and then i know uh you know i was bitten
by dogs
seven times in my life
they had to take me to the hospital and
i know i got the rabies shot at least
twice
so um you know i have some vaccines that
i know of but you know the the common
ones i have no idea whatsoever if i ever
got a vaccine or not that's because my
mother fought against vaccines she
fought against a lot of the uh
procedures that the doctors and dentists
did she thought a lot of them were
unnecessary she was very familiar with
the fact that companies would come
to sell their products through the
doctors and giving them a cut of those
profits
you know she was well aware of all that
and i'm not talking about 2021 i'm
talking about 1961.
we're talking about 60 years ago and so
so she grew very skeptical of doctors
and that whole medicine world
but
there's a
part of the story to this and that's
that she died at the age of 62.
and she could have lived
probably a lot more a year maybe to the
80s for sure but she died relatively
young
and she died of
cancer to the uterus
now
that was an oper a relatively simple
operation if you catch it on time you
know you go in there and uh if you know
the uterus has cancer you remove it and
women live many years after that
she didn't do that because
she didn't trust doctors so she didn't
go to the doctor to get a
a test or anything she was having
problems and she kept it to herself and
you know i think that
that was the cause of her death the fact
that
she did not go to a doctor when she
should have
now you know i went to a doctor
uh what was a couple years ago i got a
an operation
you know they um
they
removed
a big circle
as far as i know this is all i know
about okay they removed something from
my prostate and they also removed the
stone in fact here you see the stone i
don't know if you see it there
okay i hope you can see that
anyways they removed the stone looks
like a limestone there okay
and um
you know
i had some kind of problems so that's
why i went to see the doctor you don't
have a problem you don't see the doctor
other than you know for a
yearly test or whatever other than that
you know you got a problem you go see a
doctor that's
normal procedure operating procedure so
i go there and they say look you need an
operation we need to cut your uh your
prostate
okay so they went out there made a hole
in it pulled it out and while they were
there they removed the stone
now you know someone might say out there
that well bill you know that's what they
told you maybe they went to
a quarry they got a little bit of stone
and they told you hey we remove this
from your bladder
um
well yeah you can have all kinds of
conspiracy theories you know out there
someone could have said also that my
mother probably didn't have colon
cancer to the uh uterus
uh maybe
uh she should have eaten carrots and
she'd be okay
you know i get those kinds of answers
uh people you know
they
your arm hurts your your shoulder hurts
you go to the internet you look it up uh
on google shoulder you know pain
and you see a million people there
saying different stories and you see one
says oh uh i don't know uh if you eat
grapes
uh your shoulder will hold and the guy
says ah yeah i hate a lot of grapes so
maybe that's why my shoulder hurts
then when he meets you you say you know
my shoulder's hurting do you eat grapes
well i ate grapes last year you know on
a saturday ah that's what it is you know
you eating grapes makes your shoulder
hurt
you know you get these kinds of answers
out there
and that's because everybody today is a
witch doctor everyone everyone's a
dietologist they all know everything
about diets what you should eat what you
should not eat what proteins are what
fats are uh what carbohydrates they know
it all
you know and so they worry about what
they eat
should you eat this should eat that
lettuce is good for the heart uh pumpkin
is bad for your liver i mean you know
they they they know it all
and uh you know i'm not into that world
at all
i don't care about you know what i i eat
what's on the plate i usually eat what i
like to eat
and you know there was a teacher in
college that said you know anything you
put in your mouth is poison
has some kind of poison you know it's
good for this but bad for that
you know and there's no way out of it
we're all going to die eventually you
know we can't beat mother nature's
gravity gravity pulls on you eventually
she has her way
so we're all going to die one way or
another
uh if the gods of olympus came
and um
said bill you know uh
i'm going to give you the uh
same um
options that i gave achilles you know
you can live a very sh a very short but
um glorious life
or a uh
a long uneventful life
which would you want
well i think i i would go with the
achilles version you know if he gave me
a choke
you know zeus or whoever gave me the
choice and said bill you got to stop
drinking beer and wine and you'll live
five more years
no
i'll take the
the last
uh five years less and continue to drink
beer you know i mean that's the way i i
don't care
so
so you know it's one of those things
that everybody has to decide for
themselves but i'm saying there's a lot
of people who out there who are very
scared of this
covet thing from two points from two
directions some people believe that
there's a big problem out there and they
want to get their shot so they're
protected so they don't get the virus
because apparently the virus kills other
people say no it's all a hoax don't
worry about it
this is all government propaganda
and the only thing i've got against that
is again like i said last week um
you can't have cuba
china russia
um
north korea iran you know these
countries which are enemies of the
united states
agree to
that there is a
you know a virus out there that's going
to kill the population i don't think
they all got together and you know and
decided on this
so i have to believe that there is a
problem out there okay
and the only issue there is that it's
counteracted by the fact that you know
companies are making good money with
this vaccine and all this other stuff
that's out there uh governments are
charging uh you know um
to get the pcr test and so on so so
there's a lot of commerce involved and
then like i mentioned the other day you
have uh like the sputnik
the russian vaccine it's not allowed
here in
europe it's not
hasn't been approved
and again you would think that if it's
for health reasons anything go anything
should be accepted hey we got to save
our population any way we can that's not
the case they say no we're not going to
accept your your vaccine we want to make
money with our own vaccine
and so there's a lot of that going on
and again that's that's why a lot of
people are skeptical
but all i can tell you is uh in my case
i'm gonna be traveling i don't want the
hassle and i don't care if they put
poison in my arm
or not as long as it doesn't kill me or
like i told my doctor i said you know i
said um can i still drink beer
if i get the shot she says
yeah sure you can i said okay
i'm gonna use that as an antidote for
whatever poison you put in my arm
so
yeah i'm not into that subject at all i
don't care one way or the other as long
as it doesn't kill me if they want to
put a little poison water or fire water
or whatever they're put in there i don't
care
uh i just want less hassle when i travel
and that's the only reason i got the
vaccine and they kind of force you to it
they they say look if you want to travel
you want a document this other country
wants to accept you you know you got to
get the shots and you say i'm not going
to get the shots i'm going to tough it
out well they're going to make life
miserable on you believe me
you're going to have to get that
vaccine if you want to travel if you
stay in at home no problem you know i
wouldn't have gotten my vaccine if i
wasn't traveling at all i wouldn't even
bother
but uh
i'm going to be traveling
okay
fella says
it says who would have thought covet
will allow to create the communist world
as in china or north korea we are
heading in that direction very fast
what worries me most is how easy most of
the people believe the big lie and how
easy for governments corporations it is
to introduce the regime uh freedom will
become a wild fantasy
okay uh i know a little bit about
communism because i dedicated so much of
my life to it you know
and what i can tell you is communism is
not is is nonsense there is no such
thing as communism as far as freedom is
concerned i i'll give you a little
anecdote uh they i think it was in the
70s uh someone in the united states a
reporter
one of these shows they interviewed a
soviet
and i don't know who he was
but the guy said you know you americans
you think you are free
we know we're not
and i think that pretty much synthesizes
it
some people we're all in in a prison
we're all in in jail okay
but some people think they're free
because they can walk around the the
jail and other people who
are aware
that they can't get out and they know
they have no freedom and that's more or
less what it is all governments are
dictators uh dictatorships okay and so
it doesn't one way or another it's that
some governments make you believe
that you are free
so that's my take on that
as far as all these governments that say
oh we're a communist government like
cuba and north korea and so on now it's
they're known correctly the correct term
which is the one they use okay is that
they are a dictatorship of the
proletariat
okay that's what they are
what is the dictatorship of the
proletariat
first and foremost it's a dictatorship
okay
so
and um the way they look at it they're
working towards the future
it will be our great grandchildren who
will enjoy communism
yeah but see if you're an atheist and
you know you're not gonna go to heaven
right
uh well you may not want to wait till
you're
you
are reborn
you know five generations later to see
what came out of the world no you're
going to live your life today
and your life today is dictatorship and
that's these rulers who are there and
say oh yeah someday we're working
towards the future
someday we will have communism
and where does that leave me
well
you have to support us
that's what you got to do you got to
send your taxes you got to fight in the
military whenever they invade us you
know you go through all these things so
that our future children will live in
this paradise
uh yeah and meanwhile see the rulers
they live in great style
like you if you go to cuba you know you
see
uh the big guys up there oh the chicken
the
meat they're the meat eaters as some of
them call them down at the bottom the
people
they eat what is called this boniato
boniato is a type of potato that grows
on the island
so we have the banana
eaters and the meat eaters that's how
the society is divided and that gives
you a synthesis of what communism
equality is about you know
equal
we were all born equal
so
that's my take on communism in a
nutshell okay another foul says if your
rule about inbreeding holds true it must
apply in microcosms like isolated
populations okay small isolated
populations ought to face rapid
extinction
okay from lack of genetic diversity
uh
maybe not okay yet many species have
survived on one island for so long that
they evolve into this distinct breed or
race okay isn't genetic quality more
important than diversity
okay good question enabling people to
survive and reproduce who would
naturally have died lowers the genetic
quality of future generations is diverse
but poor quality genetics really better
than narrow but high quality genetics
extreme inbreeding
this is his conclusion from that or
where he leads to that right extreme
inbreeding prevents genetic defects from
being corrected but if the genetic
quality was already high
there may be no serious genetic defects
made apparent by inbreeding
okay
another fellow along the same lines okay
it says the the following says the risk
of food scarcity is possible but more
likely won't be a complete extinction
well he's just got to become more
familiar with the theory that i uh put
forth i don't think he's aware of it
okay but says some will survive and i've
addressed that issue no whoever survives
got a big problem okay and that's a long
story but for sure they won't reproduce
okay
uh
uh about loss of genetic diversity not
necessarily bad to have useful selected
traits more or less the same
along the same lines as this other
fellow however for humans okay
natural selection no longer happens now
also the people breed so bad so bad
genes are passed on a significant
portion of the educated middle class
does not breed enough uh-huh
uh
again uh people have this mistaken idea
that's got to do with poor people
breeding okay
and
that's not totally true
19th century it was the rich people who
procreated so do a little bit of history
look up the past and you'll find out
that it was the rich people who had
children not the poor people it was the
other way around uh you don't believe me
go to the bible okay and you'll find out
that israel
jacob yeah he had um
he was a cattle rancher essentially you
know he uh not cattle but sheep or
whatever they had in those days
he was a rancher he was a rich man
and
he had four wives you know with the two
uh
slaves that he slept with
and he had 12 children plus a little
girl there right
so
it was the rich people who were
procreated and why because they wanted
to bequeath
their um
their land
their
whatever they work for throughout their
life they wanted to bequeath that to
their the next generation
so it's not true that poor people
breed
it's people who are in the country
primarily who breed when they come to
the city uh they stop breeding
maybe not the first generation for sure
the second generation um
women when they especially women right
but men do but mainly women when they
come to the city from the country you
know they still might have children or
they might bring the children with them
but those children they will not
reproduce
and they're still poor but they're not
going to have children because they're
already in the city and they don't have
the economics to maintain those children
so they're not going to have just
children for the sake of having children
in fact they don't
okay so uh look up um
again this transition from the country
to the city that's what produces
children okay when you're in the country
when you have these open spaces
it says okay so it says
that the middle class doesn't produce
enough this could cause a genetic
regression overall mixed race couples
introduce some genetic diversity this
happens more and more
and again all i can tell you inbreeding
is a bad deal no matter how you look at
it and i covered that a couple of weeks
ago here you have charles ii of spain he
was called the ichisado he was from the
habsburg family
and
his great great grandfather charles the
first okay charles v of the holy roman
empire charles the first of spain that's
why this guy's charles ii
and all the phillips that went in
between they all had the habsburg chin
and he was born they say uh [ __ ]
that's why he was called elecisado the
bewitched
because he was not mentally sane and
there are different theories on that by
the way but for sure you know the case
of alex a romanov and he was a great
grandson of queen victoria okay and
uh in the family line of queen victoria
nine people had hemophilia
why because they've been intermarrying
for who knows how long in breathing
uh the amish have been inbreeding for
300 years they have all kinds of genetic
diseases today including mental problems
okay
and humans we've been inbreeding for
over 200 000 years
um we have not
mixed with anybody else and so yeah
i don't think inbreeding is a good deal
and
you can justify it any way you want
saying oh we have the good genes the bad
genes if we eliminate the bad genes
we're still okay
and animals are on an island you know uh
a few animals there with the same
genetic code they're okay
um
all i can tell you is don't inbreed if
you inbreed you're gonna die you can't
continue inbreeding forever okay you
might do it for
uh
non-geological time maybe a hundred
years something like that
sure you cannot do it for forever okay
uh and in the end
inbreeding is the end of a species in
fact uh
i i argue that
inbreeding or
lack of genetic diversity is what
eventually causes the extinction of a
species
in a background extinction
their population pyramid overturns then
they can only inbreed and they inbreed
themselves to death
they don't continue forever but if you
look at the some animals for a short
while only in a few years they say well
here we have a few animals on the island
and they all have the same genetic code
yeah i'm wondering how long that's going
to last does it get last
50 years 100 years a thousand years a
million years
no that's the end of those animals okay
uh so that's all i can tell you yeah you
can believe whatever you want i'll tell
you my theory and my theory is that
inbreeding
leads to extinction
uh you have created a new branch of
science one guy says extinctiologist
uh no
a paleontologist is an extinctiologist
okay
the only job a paleontologist has is
telling you how species became extinct
that's what paleontology is 150 about
once he figures out how extinction
happens both background meaning one
species
or mass many species we're done with
paleontologists
we don't need paleontology anymore okay
we're done with it anything else is
known as stem collecting
this uh thing about collecting bones in
the field dusting
them assembling the bones for a museum
that's not paleontology that's stamp
collecting
paleontology excellent geologist you got
to tell me how specie died in the past
okay
and he asked me to go and check this guy
uh michael cremo
and
this fellow says that or believes or
theorizes that humans have been around
for 40 million years that it's a mistake
to say we've been only around maybe for
200 300 000 years we've been around for
40 million years that's his argument
too lengthy to cover here but uh my
answer is my my short answer is
no
[Laughter]
uh but uh you know listen what happens
when people find something in the field
they interpret what they find and they
reach these outrageous conclusions
[Music]
you got to use your brain not not
evidence
evidence is not sufficient to create a
theory it helps but mainly it helps to
convince people including yourself
that's different than theorizing and
saying okay
if this is true what can i explain with
that okay and that's when you run into
trouble to say that humans have been
around for 40 million years because you
found i don't know a bullet uh in the
rock dated to 40 million years ago and
say ah see there were humans here
because this bullet could have only come
from that
well maybe there are many other types of
explanations for that and not the one
people like this gentleman is thinking
of okay so
theories
they have to be rational and
rationality works more or less hand in
hand with common sense okay it's not a
exact match but
you got to use common sense the least
common of all senses
okay another fellow says
i have a terrible suspicion why they
want to vaccinate at all
okay
bill says that humans practically no
longer have any genetic diversity yeah
we've lost genetic diversity uh we are
all essentially clones of each other
eight billion clones for the most part i
mean there are differences obviously but
the
differences we have could be cosmetic
okay
they're not really profound so
whoever you marry today you're marrying
your brother or your sister from a
genetic point of view that's how close
we are all all of us on earth today we
descend from the same
billion people in 1820 who descended
from the same 300 million at the
beginning of the christian year who came
from the 10 million who came maybe 10
000 years earlier
and we didn't come from all of those
because again you have
bottlenecks population bottlenecks some
disease war whatever that came in
chopped a big chunk of
population
and then from there what you have is a
smaller base which is the founder effect
that creates the next generation and if
you do that many times well all you're
doing is streamlining the genetic code
that's where we are today okay so that's
the argument okay could it be that they
want us to create diseases through
vaccination
so uh we put a vaccine okay in your body
like they put in my
uh body and
what this does is compel you
to your body or you right if you're
gonna procreate right uh to
adjust
to the new uh vaccine right so now you
change your code in relation to that
maybe not you in one generation maybe
over two or three generations and
suddenly we have more genetic diversity
because now uh we fought against the new
environmental
uh problem which is the vaccine the
poison they put in your arm okay or in
your veins or whatever
this is more or less his argument here
okay
so that individual from diseases and the
species become immune and thereby
quasi-new genetic diversity develops
through vaccination in short so that the
human species does not die out
immediately it exists much longer okay
that's his argument okay
and
what can i say about that
all i can say uh you know i don't think
we're gonna
create a new diversity more genetic
diversity
through vaccines okay this takes
many generations and it takes us moving
into new environments
and there are no new environments we can
move into even if we move to mars by the
way okay
let that be clear you go to mars
you bring your house with you
you bring your air you bring everything
that you need to live in mars so even
though it's a totally different
environment you know
it's not like you move in there and
start breathing you know co2
[Laughter]
now when you go there you're going to
take your own air you're gonna
you know your whole uh equipment with
you
you're probably gonna grow the same
plants that you have here on earth etc
etc etc so it's like you never left home
you you're not forcing your body to
adjust to anything
that's different than when we migrated
okay
like humans apparently migrated from
africa to europe that's at least a
theory that i vouch for
neanderthals evolved in europe okay they
evolved with cold
and so
you know
that's when you have genetic diversity
and
you create
more and more genetic diversity when you
first settle but then you enter this
period where you're more or less
stationary you're sedentary you get used
to the endemic diseases you get used to
the cold and after that it's all the way
down you lose genetic diversity through
um
bottlenecks and
founder effect
a whole cycle of them over thousands of
years
and so you know the if you look at the
neanderthals they've determined through
genetic analysis
that
they lost genetic diversity there was no
genetic diversity among neanderthals
they say there was none among the
denisovans okay
[Music]
none of them had any genetic diversity
left at the end of their lives and
that's where we're at now fortunately
we're not going to die through loss of
genetic diversity or population pyramid
overturn we're going to die in a mass
extinction and that's an economic
collapse ecological collapse okay
okay uh here's uh
something that came in the news related
to this subject okay it's this lady and
uh says the antwer zoo says woman who
had affair with chimp asked to stay away
for his health for the chimp's health
and she said we're having an affair
what is this all about
uh are we sleeping with chimps now uh to
have um
what's he called uh trying to get a
human see out there you know uh a
mixture between humans and chimpanzees
you know you get a human z well that if
we could have one like that well i'm
sure the the genetic would be a little
of that individual would be very
different than the rest of humanity okay
and here is what this lady says okay uh
she's from belgium uh belgium says i
would say you know uh she says and um
let's wait until it starts here
uh she kisses the
the chimp
i guess uh the chimp's wife got jealous
and asked for a divorce
and she said she's having an affair with
with the chimp and says he's 38 years
old
okay
and i'm saying okay uh maybe was the age
difference between them or something
maybe maybe he did not give his consent
was that it
uh maybe his wife uh asked for a divorce
because he was
cheating on her you know the
chimp cheating on the chimp
they tried to create a uh human see in
the
1820s a russian guy and he failed
miserably he went out there and asked
for
uh
women who wanted to who were willing to
be donors
and a woman came forward and she was
impregnated by
the chimp
and it never happened uh nothing came
out of there okay and this is the issue
a lot of uh i get people who say
well humans will sleep with anything
and i have to believe these people are
mentally [ __ ] okay they're mentally
[ __ ] they don't understand what the
issue is
you know the guy can go behind a cow
and do whatever he wants you know you're
not going to have a minotaur come out of
there
the issue is reproduction not sex
these people are thinking of sex they're
saying we'll have sex with anything yeah
you can have sex with a fly you can't
have a sex with a spider you're going to
get spiderman you're going to have a sp
sex with a fish you're going to have
aquaman i mean what is this we're
talking about reproduction
see the issue here is that the
um people uh in in the
genetic world especially uh the what is
it the max planck institute they claim
that uh humans slept with neanderthals
and out of that union
we have
all these
missing links that lead to us
and that we lost eventually all that
genetic
influence from the neanderthals they
died out and we have neanderthal blood
in this what they uh
suggest in fact more than suggest it's
proven already so you gotta accept it is
that the neanderthals died because they
interbred with us it's the admixture
theory okay um anyways uh for this uh
lady that she slept with the
with the chimp she didn't really sleep
with a chimp but uh that's what it
looked like at first that's why i went
on the news
and uh but but there was a big change in
all zoos on earth because of what she
did you know it used to be that they had
this uh sign up there says please don't
feed the animals okay
and now they had to change it they said
please do not have sex with the animal
so uh yeah please don't have sex with
the animals uh zoos are off limits okay
uh maybe circuses as well okay so don't
sleep with the animals and as far as the
uh
max planck institute is concerned you
know they say we slept with that guy and
that the females are are
unfaithful women you know they're always
unfaithful and they were sleeping with
that monster there
yeah sure
and and uh so what they do is what
they've done since then is make
neanderthal ever more like us if you
look at you know the uh
the sequence this year this century uh
well the 20th century is that uh nando's
has
become more and more like us over the
years
uh you know they they started with that
gorilla you saw there and they ended up
with a blonde blue eyed guy from
hollywood
that's how
that's been the um
what is it the evolution of neanderthals
in the 20th century
believe it or not
okay folks uh
we're gonna be doing a little bit of uh
physics now okay
and what do we do today we're gonna find
out something about
the speed of light or velocity of light
if you will you know whichever one you
want okay
and um
there's two problems in in the speed of
light and you know they say that yeah
you have einstein on one hand
uh through
special relativity he uh had this um
principle of
special relativity one of them says that
um
light travels at a constant speed
okay through the vacuum let's clarify
that through the vacuum light travels at
a constant speed speed is 300 000
kilometers per second
uh rounding off
okay
and no one can live with that and to
this day
we're talking about 100 years later
um people say something else they talk
about faster than light
they talk about tachyons
uh you've got what the um
enterprise
it travels much faster than that it
travels at warp speed
what is warp speed it's the speed of
thought you think you're on the other
side of the universe and you're there
and you say well okay that's hollywood
that's science fiction no no uh
believe me they're talking about again
tachyons so they ponder those things
uh they talk about phase shifts within
light
they sneak it in any way they can and so
even though on the one hand they they
say
light travel that einstein proved
mathematically etc etc that light
travels at 300 000 kilometers per second
and it doesn't travel faster or slower
in vacuum
they overrule that to this day they keep
overruling that and they want you to
believe
that yeah
theories can be overruled
so einstein's a hero but then we
overrule him anyways because we want to
travel faster in light why do we want to
travel faster in light because otherwise
uh nasa uh european space agency
japanese space agency all these agencies
are dead they're dead because there's no
way we can reach the nearest star
you know
proxima centauri 4.3 light years away
round trip
close to 90 years
we can't go to the nearest star
at the velocity of light we got to
improve on that
and we're
billions of years away from that speed
in fact einstein said you can't travel
at the speed of light because you become
energy
so we got a problem uh because on the
one hand they give
you know uh they bow down to einstein
okay
and they say oh einstein he was so great
he discovered among other things
this uh constancy of the speed of light
and then on the other they say by the
way we're going to overrule him we're
going to throw all that away because we
need to make people believe that you can
indeed travel faster than light
and the question is why can't you
because i mean particles travel faster
travels faster at the speed of light
right okay fine why can't they travel
faster
i mean what's the physical impediment
okay so that's what we're going to be
looking at and we can trace it to two
problems okay the first problem is
language
mathematical physics thrives on
irrational language
and the second problem is the word
object mathematics has no use for
objects so they never worried about
defining the word object in a scientific
way
and they use the informal version which
is an irrational version which is the
one of ordinary speech which is the c
touch criteria okay
if you can see it or touch it that's an
object okay and so that brings in
experiment because experiments can only
be done on things that you can see or
touch
and the invisible stuff that serves as
mediator uh like for gravity magnetism
well we're gonna put particles in there
particles particles particles and north
particles it's all done with particles
and when you say well the explanation is
irrational and say well that's
philosophy
that's more or less what we have today
and so we have two problems and the main
one uh at least the starting point is
language we have a problem with language
and so here we have one fellow and he
says the following says saying that
plasma is not an object because you have
to ionize gas first is like saying that
steam is not an object because you have
to boil water first
plasma is what charged particles
with separation not separated
just like steam as water molecules with
separation
god can create a cloud of steam without
first needing to create water and boil
it
i don't know who it is you think keeps
claiming that plasma involves motion but
they are feeding you baloney all
substances look solid when you uh take a
freeze frame
well uh so many errors
absolutely so many errors let's go with
the first one and that's that steam
is a concept there is no physical object
called steam sorry okay again you're
using
uh
the language of ordinary speech okay the
one mathematics have has taught you and
so people just follow this uh
this language that mathematical physics
has and they go with it and we're
challenging that uh language okay so
here you have steam okay steam what is
steam steam is water in the gas phase
okay
due to evaporation or due to boiling
where heat is applied that's wikipedia
dictionary says more or less the same
thing steam water in the form of an
invisible gas or vapor change to this
form by boiling
okay
so what is steen steam is
boiling water hot water okay you have to
have the hot in there
whenever you have an adjective
in in front
of a noun in physics okay in science not
in ordinary speech okay let's get that
straight whenever you have an adjective
in front or an adverb for that matter
but that's in front of a verb right
whenever you have an adjective in front
of a
an object a noun of physics only objects
can serve as a noun in physics you have
an adjective in front of a noun
always 150 percent of the time it's a
concept
okay
there is no such thing as a black cat in
science in physics
there's a thing called a cat
okay no such thing as a black cat black
cat concept
you're already comparing something okay
and same with steam
steam if you just point to a freeze
frame you call it gas vapor
you want okay
but
that thing you're looking at steam
is not steam
it's it's gas
okay
now if you want it to be steam you got
to have it moving
okay so let's get that one first in
there okay
and uh here's uh
the other issue we talked about ions
there what is
an ion uh well it's a
gas
that's been
where you take an electron out of the
atom essentially okay that's what it is
so what is it here well when you look it
up you find that every time you look at
the word ion you find all these
processes they're all in motion
they're called ionization and people say
well ionization is not an ion
well
you're wrong
you're wrong ionization and ion are
synonyms okay there is no physical
object called an ion okay let's get that
first before we move to plasma okay so
here we have an ion a particle atom or
molecule with a net electrical charge
electrical charge what is charge
well charge is something in motion in
fact um
the value on charge is 1.6 times 10 to
the minus 19 coulombs
and what is a number number is something
in motion
okay
counting that's what
number is so if an ion has something to
do with charge
electrical charge again a um
uh we got a problem because it's a
concept okay and so that's the first
thing you gotta absolutely understand on
an electrically charged atom or group of
atoms formed by the loss
or gain loss and gain or gain
are both uh
verbs
okay i i know it's this is news to you
loss and gain uh are both verbs okay so
there's motion
already embodied in the definition of
ion okay more fundamental than that if
you can define the term it's a concept
okay in science we do not define objects
in science we point to objects and name
them
table chair light uh lamp whatever
you you can't uh you you don't define
objects you point to them okay in
physics
in religion that's something else
mathematics uh ordinary speech we don't
care about any of that in physics you
have to point a name okay so if you can
define the word
100
of the time it's not an object it's a
concept okay
okay uh so it says the word iron was
coined from the greek ion a cation right
is something that moves down and an
anion is something that moves up
move
move move okay it's moving
loss gain okay
ions are formed
by the gain or loss of electrons okay
and atoms can be ionized by bombardment
with radiation or the transfer of
electrons between atoms and molecules
so um yeah if uh what is plasma plasma
is ionized gas
then it has the word plasma is already
it
it already embodies motion that's
different than gas gas does not embody
motion
okay
uh i can point to gas and the word gas
does not contain any motion
intrinsic motion in it
on the other hand the word plasma there
is
motion embodied in the word in the
definition of the word plasma because
it's being ionized in the photograph
that's what you're saying you have a
you're saying it's you can take a
snapshot of plasma no you cannot if you
take a snapshot of plasma what you have
is gas
okay and you say well but it's ionized
what do you mean it's ionized you mean
something happened in the photograph
you removed an electron is that what
you're saying it's charged
so no the word plasma embodies motion
just like the word steam embodies motion
just like the word ion embodies motion
okay
and yeah it's very hard for some of
these people especially from the
electric universe to understand that
okay so here we have hydrogen atom
if you ionize it you don't get an ion
what you get is proton
proton is an object an ion is not an
object okay an ion is something that
happened to an atom
okay and uh i don't know how else to get
that true to you
uh
again
you got to use a little more
intelligence but if you don't have the
intelligence well i can't help you okay
okay
here's uh again
the difference between gas and plasma
gas you can take a picture of okay i
don't need to have gas moving in order
for it to be gas
plasma is something else plasma you need
to remove the electron from at least one
atom for it to be plasma otherwise it's
not plasma okay if i if if i freeze the
universe all those electrons move back
probably to to their atoms if i stop the
whatever influence the gas is under
okay
you have to do something to the plasma
and the word plasma already embodies
motion and unless you get that through
your thick skull you won't under you'll
be a
follower of the electric universe that's
that's how bad it is okay
so yeah anyone dealing with the word
plasma uh is
you know cougar in the head
mentally [ __ ] okay we we treat all
people who use the word plasma is
mentally [ __ ] here okay
and i guess all these people from the
electric universe
okay um
another fellow
he raises this issue says uh
maxwell described light as propagating
wave of electric and magnetic fields
in mathematical physics he calls it
physics again a field is a quantity
what is it it's a quantity is a quantity
a physical standalone object
no quantity is a concept
okay there's no physical object called
quantity
he's saying these are his words he got
this okay he's right but i mean i'm just
saying that these are not my words these
are his words represented by a number
what is a number a concept
number mean the word number means to
count it's a verb
not a noun in physics
or for the purposes of science in
ordinary speech and mathematics
yeah they think number is a noun
it's not a noun in physics in physics
number is a verb the verb to count okay
so if it's a quantity or a number an
amount we don't care
concepts dynamic concepts counting okay
that has a value what is value a concept
for each point in space and time he's
right that's the definition of the word
field
a value at each point in time you see it
there at the bottom and we have values
numbers
and they make these numbers vibrate very
scary stuff
field starts vibrating all the numbers
start vibrating and it usually goes from
more
stronger to weaker as you can go out uh
farther away from an object whether it's
uh
an electrode or whether it's the earth
you know a gravitational field
it gets weaker as you go out that's the
notion of field what are they talking
about they're talking about the values
of the strength of the field at each
point in space around an object
okay so he's got it right that's the
definition for the word field if you can
define it it's a concept there's no
physical standalone object called field
okay
and it says this has led physics to con
physicists to consider electromagnetic
fields to be
a physical entity he says
physical and well we need to determine
it's a physical entity or a concept is
it an object or is it a concept can't be
both
concepts we define object we point to
objects have shape concepts don't
so god cannot be
both a human you know figure that
creates the universe
and also love
or intelligence
no no god cannot be a concept and also a
physical object he's got to be he's got
to choose
and he can only exist as if he's a
physical object if he's a concept he
doesn't exist
and
nevertheless is that what you pray to
you pray to a concept
hopefully the concept has an ear to hear
you you know
okay uh so yeah we got a problem with
language that's my point here uh all the
this language as you can see comes from
refining uh these concepts into objects
okay they convert
concepts into objects they talk about
field they talk about energy they talk
about mass and everybody thinks they're
you know they're talking about physical
objects because they say
phrases like transfer energy
what do you mean you transferred energy
how do you transfer a concept
they transferred information how do you
transfer information
i mean uh
did you carry it with your hands
how do you transfer information
what have you trained how does it
transform
information move
you know so they talk about uh sending
information at the speed of light or
whatever
nonsense that's mathematics in science
we don't transfer information it's very
scary stuff okay don't ever do that
okay so the problem is language and here
let me show you a little story okay
here you have uh
martian he comes to earth
okay
and uh he looks like that cat there okay
and what does the cat do uh felix you
know he he revolves um
this uh
mass
and he does it with so much energy
rolls around throws it and breaks the
window with force
that's more or less how a math magician
explains a physical interpretation
explains how the window broke
you know so the window broke because
what mass was thrown with such
or so much ener energy that the
magnitude of the force shattered the
glass in one picosecond
those are the concepts they use and they
say we explained it
they explained it they explained the
mechanism how the window broke
no i don't think so
i don't think that's an explanation let
me show you how a physicist does it or
how the language is totally different
okay
and this is how we do it in science okay
and the language of physics is
illustration not mathematics and we say
that the window broke when a horseshoe
went through the glass
okay
and i hope you can see the difference
there is a little bit of difference
qualitative difference here okay
in one case uh they're throwing concepts
around which they reified
and in science we don't do that and
sometimes we have to explain how the
window broke
okay
so this is the first issue
okay uh hopefully
uh that became clear okay
and what's the issue the issue here is
language again okay that's the major
problem
and here let me surprise some of these
people and i know i'm going to get a lot
of feedback is called
for this
these are the verbs concepts that people
mistake for objects steam is a concept
it's a verb okay it's boiling
you don't concentrate on the word water
you concentrate on the word boiling okay
that's what steam is wind it's moving
air okay
so is a tornado and a hurricane all
those are moving air the object is air
okay and you're moving it that and then
we call it hurricane under this
circumstance tornado under that whenever
whirls around or whatever
vortex
no such physical object as a vortex
a when you take a snapshot of vortex you
get a cone usually an ice cream cone
okay
plasma uh
concept
okay it's a dynamic concept you have to
ionize
almost every atom in the uh soup
okay that means the electron has to be
removed from the atom okay in order for
it to be plasma and you have to be doing
it
uh and you can't do it in a single frame
obviously okay so if you're doing it you
got a verb there you got a movie plasma
is a movie always a movie because you're
doing something to the atom and again
electric universe people have tremendous
mental uh barriers to understand the
language and that's what we're talking
about here language you gotta get the
language straight before you can do
physics these people never do language
they consider that a job for english
majors maybe librarians
that's why they don't define words they
look them up in the dictionary say well
let's see what the dictionary says well
we don't have a single definition worth
anything for science and for physics in
the dictionary so don't look at the
dictionary because they're all all the
words have been misdefined for the last
10 000 years
and uh yeah gas is a physical object on
the other hand uh ion is not a physical
object an ion is what a concept
ion means that you're removing an
electron from an atom
when you do so at least for the hydrogen
atom what you get is a proton proton is
a physical object if if
because you can talk about that ball in
the center we'll even take the quantum
person no problem but if you're going to
talk about that ball in the center
that's a physical object we call that a
proton
when you put the electron back in we
call it an atom as is okay we have
problems with uh going around but uh
because it's a composite object okay so
it's not really an object but when we
talk about atoms constituting molecules
we treat them as objects ion is
something else iron means you gotta do
something to the atom plasma you're
going to do something to the gas steam
you're going to do something to the
water
when you're going to do something to the
air
when you do something it's a concept
dynamic concept it's no longer a
physical object
like i like to say a jumping kangaroo is
not a physical object the
object is known as kangaroo okay
okay um here are some other words that
we let me put over here
that we usually
mathematical physics
reifies electricity there's no physical
object called electricity sorry
electricity is a verb it's a concept
dynamic concept in fact
and when i tell that to the people of
the electric universe they say well why
don't you put your fingers in an outlet
you'll find out if it's an object
and that's not how we determine objects
in science
in science we define the word object and
if it meets the definition of the word
object it's an object otherwise it's not
see how easy it was but you can go ahead
and put your fingers in there to try to
prove
that electricity is an object okay and
what's funny about the electric universe
they never defined the word electricity
they've given up on that as i've shown
in the past and they say it's an
undefined word but let's continue you
know what we're talking about that's the
way they put it and electric is in the
title of electric universe
and then the uh even worse they say
that all galaxies are interconnected by
these filaments
how can they be interconnected by
filaments if the atom
of
the electric universe is the planetary
model
and electricity according to them is
this flow of electron beams from atom to
atom how do you create continuity with a
little bead going from atom to atom how
do you create these filaments
so they have a contradiction because uh
they want to say that the filaments
unite or hold together all these objects
and turns out when you go to the
nitty-gritty all these
filaments are made of atoms
and
the atoms are all planetary atoms with
the beads going from one electron from
one um
atom to another
right
and so when you have the flow of these
beads how do you create this
this this rope this filament that pulls
everything together
you're building something continuous
with discrete parts you can't do that
not in science it's irrational anyways
uh time force mass energy wave charge
number all of these words are concepts
they're verbs okay displacement
perturbation so on so you can't use this
as nouns you can't use them as objects
which is exactly what mathematical
physics does
okay
just in case here are the adjectives and
adverbs okay shape is a
an adjective
okay
it's a qualifier of a noun called
an object
objects are
shape is a property
a qualifier of objects
so shape anything related to shape is an
adjective
okay sorry i know
you learned that this is a noun not in
physics okay so you gotta learn the
language of physics in order to be able
to give physical interpretations
straight okay people confuse it with
rectilinear they say i traveled straight
that's an ordinary speech in mathematics
not in science in science you travel
rectilinearly okay
and you can say rectilinear travel
whatever but the point here is that
straight is an adjective rectilinear
erected linearly are adverbs rectilinear
can only be motion same with curvilinear
versus curve bent and warped okay
location angle perpendicular all those
are adjectives those are um they tell
you it's a property of an object
there is no physical standalone object
called perpendicular therefore there is
no
noun
in physics called perpendicular and you
can't talk about perpendicular
as the subject of a sentence not in
physics
the subject is whatever object there is
and perpendicular is what it does or or
actually in the case of perpendicular
what
how it's uh positioned okay
so it's a static concept therefore it's
not an adverb okay so all these words
you gotta relearn them forget about
ordinary speech forget about mathematics
these are the how the words are used in
physics for physical interpretations
okay direction matter what does matter
uh
objects that exist what does exist
exist is an adjective it's not a verb
you don't begin to exist in
physics physics
an object that has location location
being a static concept
okay
object has no motion the word object
embodied in it so an object with
location is what is exist and all you're
doing is qualifying the object okay so
exist is an adjective
and so on down the line so you got to
learn these terms for the purposes of
physics sorry
if your religion says something
different okay but that's how we're
gonna use these words here so that
you're in tune with what we are saying
here okay
okay so now here comes the martian again
uh we had the cat right a little while
ago throwing the stone through the
window this time we have a martian okay
he comes and visits us okay and he waves
his hand
okay and suddenly a window breaks
okay
and you say how did he do that
and
i mean did he use magic is he using
spirits he just waves his hand and from
afar and suddenly the window breaks
how could he have done that
okay
and what is the issue well the issue is
that uh maybe he's not using magic maybe
he's using something that you can't see
and it turns out you ask him and he
explains look i i did it with a rock
what do you mean a rock a stone i don't
see anything in your hand i just saw
that the window broke
and he says well it turns out that you
know i did it with a rock but you can't
see the rock
because what happens is that this rock
gives off ultraviolet radiation
and you can't see you earthlings you
cannot see an ultraviolet light
and that's why you thought it was magic
but if the guy you know makes it appear
like he just draws it or shows you the
movie uh maybe a special movie that
comes from mars or wherever right
um and he shows you what he actually had
in his hand well there's no mystery then
it's kid stuff but see
while you couldn't see the stone then
you thought it was magic you thought the
guy was just throwing
you know nothing he just waved his hand
that's as far as your concern
and so
why am i bringing this up well we have
this situation
with light and especially with the
velocity of light okay
you can't see
the mediator of light in fact
you know here you have uh magnetism
you can't see the mediator of magnetism
okay there you don't see anything
between these two
but it causes some magic some incredible
magic pulls these two things together
uh here's uh another magic trick okay i
let go of the pencil
falls to the floor you do it many times
you'll find that it always falls to the
floor and so what's the issue the issue
is that you can't see the mediators
and so you get two choices okay
you either say that there's nothing
there
no mediator
or um
you know
you you meaning you do it with spirits
because
if there is no
no mediator what you're telling me is
that pencil falls always to the center
of the earth and one magnet attracts
another simply because either there's
ghosts and spirits
or
you're going to introduce black magic
you're going to say
two magnets come together
is that what happens
or is there a physical object that you
can't see or touch
which one is it
so you know you have the materialists
that say
there's a physical object in there i
just can't see or touch it and yeah
spiritual this which is 99 of humanity
probably out there that says oh there's
nothing there it's uh spirits
uh
because i can't see or touch it there's
nothing there
those are the two choices and of course
most of humanity just believes there's
nothing there because you can't see or
touch it and that's our daily experience
that you gotta see and touch something
for it to be a physical object
and that's easily solved
we redefine the word object so that it
doesn't include see or touch
okay
we call say that an object is that which
has shape okay and so here are some
examples of quantum mechanics where
because you can't see or touch the
objects okay
they've come up with uh let's see
oh
uh
there we go here we have entanglement
okay
and so what what happens here well
you're saying that one object uh
influences the other object with nothing
in between them
called the entanglement they call it
einstein podolsky rosen the epr test
and
what they say is that one object one
ball affects the other one one goes
clockwise the other one counterclockwise
and vice versa
uh
at a distance without any mediator being
in between them
so so this is what's so scary that
they give you these explanations
and people just believe and they just
swallow them because they come from phds
they say well he studied at the
university he must know
i don't care where he studied i mean if
he's going to tell me that
there's nothing in between these two
objects this one affects that one over
there well we got two choices again we
either put spirits and do things but
with black magic
or we have to assume that there is a
physical object that we can't but see or
touch
okay so those are the two choices you
have no other choice okay
okay another experiment that uh shows
that quantum also does magic okay
without objects is this when they say
look
particles can be at two places at the
same time
and it can be excited not excited at the
same time
and how can you understand this you know
how does how can an object how can a
particle be at two places at the same
time
so so they have all these explanations
and we have to assume that quantum is
simply not a rational
theory
because these are their physical
interpretations
and again they do it all with magic and
they do it all with ghosts and goblins
spirits
acting in between two objects
and it's like people have gotten so used
to it they don't even question it
anymore they say well quantum has been
proven because otherwise you wouldn't
have a computer that works right so
that's the
answer you get the kind of answers you
get
okay uh here here are three
possibilities at least today we used to
have only two now we have three okay you
have the particle hypothesis you have
the wave hypothesis and now we have the
rope hypothesis we have three versions
of what light might be
and the first question i've got for you
is here you have particles up there okay
why doesn't
why can't those particles travel faster
why can't they travel faster than like
why can't they travel faster than 300
000 kilometers per second
okay
that's the question same for the one-way
waves
no physical object called wave but let's
concede that let's forget about fighting
that issue why can't the wave travel
faster what prevents the wave
physically right from traveling faster
do you have an answer for that do you
can you think about that and give me an
answer
okay and so here you have uh again the
quantum versions okay
uh let's see
uh in the case of the robbie i don't
know what happened here
oh i think it's this one hold it see
here you have the particles and the
waves
and the question here you have different
speeds for the particles let's assume
the one on top is traveling 300 000
kilometers per second why can't these
particles travel faster like the ones in
yellow there and how about the wave you
have a wave that travels slow and i know
and travels fast why why can't we travel
faster than light
and here on the right hand side you see
why we can't you know under the rope
model the role model explains quite well
that frequency is inversely proportioned
to wavelength
okay if it's inversely proportional it
means that the velocity of light is
constant all we're changing is frequency
for in exchange for wavelength under the
rope model it's length length versus the
number of links
okay and so now now we have an
explanation for why
the velocity of light is constant and
why you cannot travel faster than light
because all you can do is increase the
frequency at the expense of wavelength
and vice versa that's the situation
okay
okay so we don't have an explanation for
from quantum mechanics let me get rid of
these here
and uh we do have an explanation under
the rope model
that's the main point okay so uh someone
asks
he says um
yeah
give me a second here
it says what's the earliest instance of
c equals frequency times wavelength that
you have found i can't seem to find the
innovator of the equation
it's an important question it's an
important question because
it's so hard to find this type of
information one and second because
no mathematician is
specifically aware of this equation c
equals frequency type times wavelength i
mean they're aware of it but it's like
no one pays attention to it it's they
don't ask why is that the case
why does frequency exchange for from
with wavelength
why did einstein say that
light travels
no faster if
if you throw the ball you know if you
throw the photon ball from a train
moving train why don't you add the speed
of the train to the speed of the photon
ball
that was the issue
and and they haven't they have no
explanation for that today
under the rope model you do have an
explanation but but nobody nobody's
familiar with this equation it's not um
imbued in the minds of mathematicians at
all they heard about it maybe they
forgot about it but they don't care
about it
okay
and so yeah um
this is the history okay if just for
your inter for your sake of your
interest right uh these were the people
who worked on the wave equation uh
darling birth uh
euler and bernoulli they were two swiss
swiss uh
mathematicians
and
all these people
lagrange and maxwell they all worked on
the wave equation okay but it was all
math there was no attempt
to
try to make sense of it from a physical
point of view that's where the problem
was
and so it doesn't really matter
uh who came up with it and
how they discovered it or what math they
made they did behind it to justify it
the point here is that we have this
equation we're all aware of it today
nobody pays any attention to the exp to
the equation no one tries to explain it
of why it's the case
and for the first time we do have an
explanation we're saying you know if you
take the rope
all you can do is uh if c is equal to
frequency times wavelength in other
words c little c being the velocity of
light 300 000 kilometers per second all
you can do is change the number of links
for the link length
and here you see it there there's the
magic trick the links became longer and
you have fewer links
so we can't explain that equation which
is the equation of a rope there's no
other
entity that can simulate that equation
so if you want evidence well for those
people who like evidence you think
evidence is part of science there you
have evidence try to explain why that's
not the case
okay thought i had a glitch there
okay so what are the conclusions let's
see if we can move on to them
if i can get it up here
okay conclusions mathematical physics
thrives on irrational language okay they
move the mass they transfer the energy
they also transfer information very
scary stuff
mathematical physicists propose
irrational physical interpretation
simply because they can't see or touch
the invisible intangible mediators okay
so
they can't see the mediator of light and
so they put particles in there for
example but then they don't explain why
light cannot travel faster
than 300 000 kilometers per second
because there's no reason not to why
can't the particles go faster why are
they limited physically limited at 300
000 kilometers per second
under their old model it's very easy you
know one
frequency exchanges with wavelength how
do you explain that with particles
so clearly the
particle hypothesis meaning the quantum
hypothesis is irrational
we cannot explain anything with it okay
and um as an uh an object is not that
which you can see or touch which takes
the mathematicians to the lab
you know they're trying to see and touch
that which is invisible and
okay
an object is that which has shape and it
doesn't mean that you can see or touch
it so there's no use in going to the lab
you can stay at home and just try to
visualize think
and you'll reach your answer not by
going to the lab you'll do it with your
brain okay
and quantum particles and waves are not
objects for the purposes of physics and
the quantum particles are the zero
dimensional point particles remember
that's not an object for the purposes of
physics it's a concept and not even a
rational concept but it is a concept
nevertheless
and the electromagnetic rope explains
the constancy of the speed of light
which quantum cannot okay
okay let me answer some of the questions
that people ask since last time
one file says
you can try to prove your orthodox
belief
believe
uh
that the ground under your our feet is
orbiting the light source we observe
moving across our sky each day i mean in
the sun right use science i'm not a flat
earther it looks like you are huh i'm
interested in your evidence
well the answer is that we don't talk
about proof we don't talk about belief
and we don't talk about evidence in
science that's totally religion why
because
evidence is introduced to persuade
convince recruit the jury that's what
it's for you're trying to convert people
and that's why you introduce evidence
evidence has to do with proving
and changing your beliefs and all that
has to do with religions we don't do
that in science in science we explain so
that you understand
you can reach your own conclusions in
your dark basement we don't care it has
nothing to do with science okay
and along the same lines another fellow
says
all these people are into proof and
evidence okay says sorry but your
experiment for gravity is not a true
scientific experiment
thank god because in science we don't
have scientific experiments
no such monster in science okay
so scientific experiments we have no
idea what that is uh you should
go to a church and find ask your
priest what a scientific experiment is
okay
science we don't do experiments
scientists in science we explain
them okay in physics we explain that
okay things falling is the natural
effect observed yeah right things do not
always drop anyway uh okay we float in
water and hot air uh or helium balloon
rises okay so
uh he's saying that's i guess uh
violates gravity
or the law of gravity or whatever
how does your presumptive assertion
account for these conditions what is the
demonstrated mechanism of action well i
explained that many times but the
issue here is
his language talks about demonstrating
one thing is demonstrate like an
explanation you know physical
interpretation i i make a movie of it
and in that sense i demonstrate what is
happening in the invisible world
if he's talking about demonstrating in
any other sense like maybe an equation
or i'm not sure or running an experiment
here in front of him yeah here's the
experiment for gravity okay you let go
of the pen
and foster ground there i demonstrated
gravity
again we're talking about explanation
versus description
so the question is what does he mean by
demonstrate you have not proved any
valid hypothesis thank god yeah in
science we don't prove okay again these
people talk about evidence descriptions
proving running experiments
none of it has to do with science or
with physics
physics we explain
that's what physics is about that's what
science is about explaining you have not
established any true insight into the
cause of the observed effect yes i have
i you just missed i missed the
explanation some other videos that i
have out there humans did not hold any
insight into what they term gravity well
mathematicians don't we do we we have an
explanation we have a physical
interpretation for
how gravity works and that's that as an
object approaches another the
acceleration is due to the fact that the
ropes are fanning out more and more and
more the closer two objects get together
why because all their atoms are
physically interconnected okay and so
that's in a nutshell the explanation
i've got many videos on the issue just
got to look up gravity under the site
okay uh we have these people who believe
that light goes through they use that
term light goes through light goes
through light goes through in fact
someone started today with that light
goes through
when are they going to forget about
light goes through no light doesn't
travel
light twirls in place so there is no
going through
so how does light go through a glass
lens well i explained that the other day
they're all interconnected all the atoms
are connected and so uh signal is
relayed from atom data that's how it
goes in a nutshell look up a couple
videos be behind this one and you'll
find how light goes through
okay
no light does not go through it it's
relayed that's how it goes through
if the substance of light is smaller
than the substance of the glass and
again they're looking at little
particles going through other particles
and whether there's enough space for the
particle to go through okay if the
suspense life is larger okay and then
truth is that we have no idea what light
is
very simple
propose
an idea of what light is all you have to
do is propose a model and then we'll
know what light is
according to you
okay
now if you don't know well that's
then you shouldn't say we have no idea
you should say i have no idea
okay but yeah in science um
it's very simple you want to know what
light is
propose a
uh mediator for light and you'll know
what light is okay then you can explain
how light behaves to all of us
okay how's that for or an action item
atoms are modeled and not actual yes
exactly you're totally right we model
atoms
okay
now uh
are they actual
uh mother nature determines that if you
hit it on the nose and and you figured
out how the atom what the atom looks
like
uh and what light looks like etc what
magnetism whatever
object is in there mother nature knows
what it is okay and she says this guy is
right that guy's wrong she knows that we
don't know
okay we don't we don't know that all we
can do is model it model our atoms
and light etc and present it to someone
so that person can understand it
that's the way science works okay
whether you believe
whether you have enough evidence to
believe whether you proved we don't care
about that in science that's religion
belief has to do with religion
subatomic quantum physics is science
fiction i totally agree there okay yeah
it's science fiction but it's not
what you think it's it's actually
irrational
okay
uh quantum mechanics like i explained a
minute ago is irrational it says stuff
like that a particle can be at two
places at once it says that um
it does entanglement without a mediator
quantum mechanics is irrational because
of that also because it reifies concepts
turns them into objects okay so
it's not that it's science fiction it's
that it's totally irrational you cannot
understand it or even visualize it you
cannot visualize energy okay because
energy is a mathematical concept so you
better not be able to visualize it okay
or you got the wrong definition of
energy
okay
human knowledge is a facade of
understanding with little real insight
into existence at all they all
still think they are going around a vast
empty void on a spinning spherical wet
rock god help them all
uh flat earther yeah obviously
yeah spinning uh what is it a wet ball
absolutely loved it
so we're in a spinning wet ball we don't
know why
but it turns out that you know like i
explained last week if every atom of
your body is physically attached to
every atom on earth now you know why you
don't fly out of the earth why you're
pulled towards the center and why water
curves around the earth okay
okay what is your definition for data
and what is your definition for
information bill well uh we don't define
the word information because it has
nothing to do with science okay
uh
we don't transfer information that's
very scary stuff when your information
you know goes across your screen oh man
that's
very very scary stuff but all i'll tell
you about information is that
it's
even more irrational to say that you
transferred information
okay information is what someone
receives
uh he gets
some signal and he processes it
and the conclusion of that process is
known as information
information is not what you send out so
to speak information is what you receive
it's on the receiving ends that you can
receiving in that you can talk about
information
okay
you cannot go in there and say i'm gonna
transfer information no you can only
receive information because
information means that you receive some
kind of signal some something there okay
or you see something
you you take it to your head you analyze
it you come up with that conclusion that
conclusion is what we call information
now you have information
until then you have no information
so the the guy sent you something what
he sent you as a signal maybe
electricity or whatever okay a torsion
and
whatever machine you use to detect that
uh detects some blip
and gives you some result
you analyze it now you have information
so just to put in these terms
information is not what you send
information is what you receive
okay i hope you understood
okay another fellow says
it's why they call it quantum theory
just the same as we call it electrical
theory it's a theory
a calculated guess and an
educated guess i guess could be wrong
no again quantum is not wrong quantum is
irrational okay
and here are some uh
reasons why it's irrational reifies
concepts states that a particle can be
at two places at once
the particle the quantum particle is not
a particle it's not a corpuscle it's an
equation okay it's a
what is it a wave function or whatever
that's what a particle is it's a concept
a mathematical concept uh proposes the
planetary model can't tell you why the
electron beat doesn't fall to the center
of the atom or fly away
okay theorizes that light is a wave no
such monster as a wave so
that's the end of that
and does entanglement with spirits and
these are just
some off the top of my head okay so you
know
again
the quantum is not
wrong it's not even wrong it's
irrational okay let's get that straight
and here you have um
criteria for
okay
we have to
treat objects as objects and concepts
and concepts what
an irrational individual does is reify
converts concepts into objects and
that's the main one so any theory of
physics where they turn a concept
especially a mathematical concept into a
physical object and start moving it
around
scary stuff
that's
what we define as irrational and then
there are other criteria for
irrationality it doesn't stop there if
you're using inconsistent definitions or
you don't define your words
that's another
irrationality that's very typical of
mathematical physics they haven't
defined any word they don't know what
mass is they don't know what time is
they don't know what space time is for
sure it's four dimensional space time
and they tell you well we don't know
what that is but let's continue
no not in science science you got to
define the key terms that make or break
your theory okay and that's where
mathematical physics fails in its
entirety and that's another
criterion for irrationality another one
is that the theory doesn't follow from
the uh
hypothesis the assumptions so you have a
set of assumptions you know
i always give the example you know
you go to court
and you present a gun
as evidence your honor here's the gun
exhibit a
okay
and then you explain your theory by
saying uh the person was poisoned
well hold it why did you present the
gun
you know i thought your theory was that
the victim was shocked
turns out that your theory is about
being poisoned or maybe a knife stuck to
her back you know so again the theory
has to follow from the assumptions okay
and there's a couple more there you can
read them okay
paul says
where does the slack in the ropes go as
objects near each other
and how does a rope stretch indefinitely
without needing more material
and i apparently
knew on this side because uh doesn't
know about the thread
single thread okay and you can find that
in the book that's in the description
okay so it's a free book downloadable
book
uh essentially the
proposal is that there's a single thread
that underlies everything in the
universe every bit of matter and every
rope that interconnects every any two
atoms
okay so that's that's the foundation and
so this thread does not extend or get
smart it's not a rubber band it's not
elastic okay it's a thread made of a
single piece
malleable
okay just like a river okay it's made of
a single piece but it waves it moves
okay
and it builds the ropes and the atoms
that are interconnected by the ropes
okay so that's the foundation
and so the ropes uh
do not bend because they're always
taught and there are other conditions
and again i urge you to
read the book
very easy to read book
not too lengthy book very heavily
illustrated so you can look at the
pictures and understand quite a bit okay
almost all of it
and that's all i can tell you it's uh
there it doesn't stretch and the slack
comes from
uh ropes and atoms that are behind the
atom
uh that you're analyzing okay so there
is no stretching there is no elasticity
to the rope okay or the thread that
builds the ropes and the atoms
okay so uh all i can do is uh tell you
to read the book
and the book is very self-explanatory
okay
so
that's all i can tell you okay
okay give me a second here
you got another
comment here
question
paul says
light is everything in the universe
all the elements have vibrational
frequencies that are created by light as
plasma as the magnetic universe turns
creating it voila life is light oh my
god uh we have the electric universe
this is the magnetic universe okay
another thing
the spirit soul of the universe is light
okay whatever he said there i have no
idea and the design creates
life as an evolving form of the design
design design means there's an
intelligence out there that is designing
a watchmaker maybe
sounds like it i mean
a parent in studying magnets electricity
plasma charge separation in space
yeah we don't understand squad of what
you said all we have is religion there
okay sorry
uh we get rid of this guy
another fellow along the same line says
theists not really say that god is
immaterial
we have we just have we just haven't saw
god but every true believer sense god
okay uh well you got to tell us whether
god is an object or a concept okay
see we can't uh see concepts i can't see
love i can't see
intelligence
i can't see the grace of god
so so the question is whether god is an
object or a concept now if god is that
guy there that's an object
and i can understand a theory saying
not that i believe it but that i can
understand the theory saying god may
waved his magic wand you know here
magic wand you need the magic wand
god waved his magic wand and he made the
universe okay we can we can understand
we can see what's going through your
mind okay not that we agree or we
believe but we can understand what what
you're trying to say okay because we can
see god
with his wand and yeah i look like god
with a one okay
um
but if god is a concept of god is
intelligence
if god is love
we cannot imagine him creating the
universe so it doesn't follow from the
assumptions okay so you got to define
what god is he's got an object or a
concept if god is an object maybe he can
hear you and he
you can pray to him but if god is a
concept i don't think he have
you know that concept called god has
ears
okay so you got to determine first what
god is okay and with that i say may your
god go with you
now we'll see you on wednesday we're
going to be here with my son we're going
to do the monthly recap